[Music]
George Clooney is one generous friend
we've been we've been great friends his
longtime pal and business partner Randy
Gerber revealed in an interview with
MSNBC's headliners Cooney gave 1 million
dollars each to 14 of his pals back in
2013 every one of us 14 of us got a
million dollars on top of that Gerber
says Clooney also paid taxes on the
gifts it was shocking apparently George
invited his group of buddies called the
boys over for dinner then the surprises
began George begins to say listen I want
you guys to know how much you've meant
to me and how much you mean to me in my
life I came to LA I slept on your couch
I'm so fortunate in my life to have all
of you and I couldn't be where I am
today without all of you so it was
really important to me that while we're
still all here together that I give back
then as a token of appreciation George
gave each guy designer luggage bags to
open inside they found 1 million dollars
worth of $20 bills so he's giving his
gifts safe to say Clooney is the best
friend
we all wish we had he's great
[Music]
you